fruit d'un côté vous l'avez vu une
initiative de paix couronné par le prix
nobel de l'autre des conflit qui
s'éternise et des plantes paix qui
s'échafaude au ralenti nos exemples pour
mieux comprendre au sri lanka c'est pour
mieux sceller un plan de paix que
l'armée indienne poursuit son offensive
contre les rebelles tamouls dans le
conflit en irak
l'échec de la mission confiée à monsieur
perez de cuellar laisse le champ libre
aux passions et surtout pas les images
horribles bilan 32 morts ce matin à
bagdad une tache de sang près d'un
cartable
c'est à bagdad un missile sol-sol envoyé
par l'iran ce matin est tombé sur une
école bilan 200 petits blessés et 30
enfants tués
le conflit entre l'iran et l'irak qui
dure depuis sept ans est entrée dans une
nouvelle phase encore plus dur ce qu'on
appelle la guerre des villes reprend la
gare des villes c'est celle qui touche
les civils et non plus les pétroliers ou
des objectifs économiques ou militaires
de leur côté les iraniens disent avoir
répliqué une attaque similaire sur leur
sol près d'une école encore ou un
missile irakien aurait lui aussi fait de
nombreuses victimes
cette escalade intervient au moment où
de nouvelles propositions de paix
discuté en ce moment à l'onu sont gelées
pour ne pas dire enlisé au moment aussi
où les signaux d'une nouvelle offensive
iranienne se précise
au sri lanka la paix n'aura pas tenu
plus de deux mois et demi pour un
conflit vieux de 14 ans entre la
majorité cinghalaise et la minorité
tamoule
les 15000 hommes de l'armée indienne
débarqué pour faire respecter le dernier
plan de paix mène depuis quelques jours
une guerre sans merci contre les
irréductibles tamouls ce dernier avait
déposé leurs armes à contrecoeur et
continue à réclamer un état indépendant
le coût humain de cette nouvelle
bataille risque d'être très lourd